it can hardly be a secret that most of
the things we say on this show we don't
just make up as we go along they're
written and I have a message from the
writers and they say quote the nicest
thing that could happen to us is an
actor who made his film debut and it
could happen to you
close quote with one voice the writers
shout save that tiger mr. Jack Lemmon
as we approach the writers Awards I'm
sure there is not one living writer out
there there's there's nobody among any
of us that wouldn't agree that we should
take a moment of reflection recollection
of memory of one of the greatest artists
of our time one of the greatest that we
will ever ever know among whose many
many gifts as he would put it was the
talent tool news so on behalf of all of
us here's to mr. Noel Coward he will
never see his likes
and quite obviously whatever lines I did
have I am NOT going to say I will now go
straight to the awards for the best
screenplay based on material from
another medium the nominees are Jay
Allen for cabaret Yantra land bank for
Celyn for the emigrants Mario Puzo and
Francis Ford Coppola for the Godfather
Julius J Epstein for Pete and Tilly
Lonnie elder the third for sounder and
the winner is Mario Puzo and Francis
Ford Coppola for the Godfather director
Francis Ford Coppola will accept the
award
my father would like to thank the
Academy for this great honor I'd like to
thank my father and I wish he could be
here now to accept this honor himself in
folk thank you very much when I came
here I was very nervous because I hadn't
I hadn't prepared anything to say should
I come up here and then after about 40
minutes I thought of something to say
but I started getting very nervous that
I would never get to come up here to say
it and I forgotten it whatever it was
firstly I'd like to thank Peter Bart who
was responsible for getting me this job
in the first place which sort of rescued
me from from my wonderful romantic
financial adventure in San Francisco
which still lives and then giving credit
where it's due I'd like to thank Bob
Town who wrote the very beautiful scene
between Marlon and Al Pacino in the
garden that was Bob town scene and
lastly I would like to congratulate Bob
Fosse and also say that the best award a
director could get would be to have
three of his best friends and and and
dear dear associates and actors Jimmy
Caan Al Pacino and Bobby du Val all get
nominated in the same category thank you
very much
the nominees for the best story and
screenplay based on factual material or
material not previously published or
produced are Jeremy Lana for the
candidates Louie Boone well in
collaboration with jean-claude carrière
for the discreet charm of the
bourgeoisie an area like that
terrence McCloy Chris Clark and Suzanne
de Paz for Lady Sings the Blues Louis my
alpha member of the hearts and Carl
Foreman for young Winston and the winner
is
Jeremy Lana for the candidates
first of all I'd like to thank Robert
Redford for his help and support our
director Michael Richie my friend Ziggy
who got me into this and all the people
watching tonight over Walters and most
of all I'd like to thank the political
figures of our time have given me
terrific inspiration I think as long as
they continue to do the things they do
and to use the words that they use words
like honor
there'll be better pictures and sharper
pictures even in the candidate thanks
very much